[موسيقى]
مساء الخير حدث العالم انفسه وامس عندما
اعلنت بولندا فجاه ان الروس بصاروخ ضرب
احدى قراها الحدوديه وقتل اثنين من
المواطنين سبب ظهور طبعا مفهومه واضح
بولندا عضو في حلف شمال الاطلسي وميثاق
حلف شمال الاطلسي او الناتو ينص على ان
الهجوم على احد اعضائه هو هجوم على كامل
الحلم
روسي قد يؤدي الى مواجهه عسكريه بين روسيا
من ناحيه وبين حلف شمال الاطلسي اي حرب
العالميه الثالثه
في اليوم التالي اي اليوم اعلن رئيس
بولندا وامين عام حلف شمال الاطلسي وقبلهم
الرئيس الامريكي ان الصاروخ لم يتم اطلاقه
من الجانب الروسي هو صاروخ روسي صحيح لكن
لم يطلقه الروس بل اطلقه هو الاوكران
الاوكران لديهم اسلحه روسيه كما ان لديهم
اسلحه غربيه في اليوم اللي حدثت فيه
الحادثه اللي هو 15 نوفمبر كان الروسي
يكثفون هجماتهم الجويه على المدن
الاخرانيه اراد الاخران التصدي لهذه
الهجمات واستخدموا مجموعه من صواريخ
الدفاع الجوي واحد من المنظومات التي
استخدموها بنظومه اس 300 الروسيه
اللي بدلا من ان تعترض الصواريخ الروسيه
ضربت القريه البولنديه بطريق الخطا هذه
الروايه الرسميه المبدايه
اذا الروس لم يهاجموا بولاندا هل انتهت
القصه عند هذا الحد الحقيقه القصه لم
تنتهي لاربعه اسباب الاولاني واضح وبديه
ان التحقيقات لم تنتهي بعد في هذه الحادثه
المؤكد ان الروس لم يهاجمه بولندا لكن من
غير المؤكد لماذا اصاب هذا الصاروخ
الاوكراني قريه هولنديه هل بطريق الخطا ام
ان هناك قوه داخل اوكرانيا تسعى لتوسيع
امه الحرب لاي اهداف تدور في اذهانهم
خصوصا في هذه الفتره الى الحديث بيعلو
فيها عن ضروره بدء المفاوضات بخلاف هذه
القصه التي سوف تظل بين اوكرانيا وبين حلف
شمال الاطلسي هناك ثلاثه اعتبارات اخرى
تجعل من هذه الحادثه ذات مغزى ولن تمر
مرور الكرام السبب الاولاني ان الحادثه دي
تفكير للجميع بان الخطوط الحمراء التي
تحكم هذه الحرب ليست الا خطوط واهيا وايه
هي الخطوط الحمراء تحدثنا عنها قبل ذلك
من هذه الحرب منذ فبراير والى الان في
خطين احمرين تم احترامهما الى حد كبير
الخط الاحمر الاول الا يقتل جنود حلف شمال
الاطلسي جنودا روسا بشكل مباشر يعني يدوا
الاسلحه للاقران فيقتل الاوكران جنودروس
لكن لا يتورث اي دوله من حلف شمال الاطلسي
في اعمال عدائيه مباشره بنفسها ضد
جنودروسال الخط الاحمر الثاني ان تظل كل
العاديات على الاراضي الاخرانيه ولا
تتعداها لا يضرب الاوكران الاراضي الروسيه
مثلا لا يزود الغرب اوكرانيا باصلحه
تمكنها من الوصول الى العمق الروسي ولا
طبعا ان الروس يقوم بضرب اي اهداف خارج
الاراضي الاوكرانيه خصوصا اذا كانت هذه
الاهداف داخل دول تنتمي الى حلف شمال
الاطلسي كما هو الحال بالنسبه ل بولندا
السبب الثاني انه رغم ان هذه الواقعه مجرد
خطا لكن سوف يترتب عليها ان الاوكران سوف
يطالبون حلف شمال الاطلسي والولايات
المتحده على وجه الخصوص بان تزودها باسلحه
اكثر تقدما لتدافع عن نفسها بشكل افضل
وبولندا سوف بل وطالبت باستخدام مزيد من
الاسلحه للدفاع عن نفسها وتامين حدودها
هولندا عندها فوبيا من الروس وهذه الفوبيا
مفهومه لاسباب جغرافيه هي قريبه من هذه
الدوله العملاقه وبنها اعداء يمتد من
بولندا وروسيا عدائي يمتد لمئات السنين
وهي عانت كثيرا من الاتحاد السوفيتي خصوصا
اثناء الحرب العالميه الثانيه وبالتالي هي
لديها بخوف كبيره جدا هذه الحادثه تعزز
هذه المخاوف وتقدها وبالتالي سوف تصر على
ان تؤمن نفسها بمزيد من الاسلحه واستقدام
قوات من حلف شمال الاطلسي
يزيد من القوات اا من حلف شمال الاطلسي
على الاراضي البولنديه مزيد من الاسلحه
المتقدمه لاوكرانيا وبولندا سوف يعمق من
الصراع بدلا من ان يهدئه
الامر الثالث ان الحادثه دي بتذكرنا بانه
دائما الحروب لها منطقها وتكلمنا في حلقه
سابقه لماذا لا يستطيع احد ايقاف هذه
الحرب وقتها يعني حتى بوت نفسه وكنا
بنتكلم على كيف تسير الحروب واحد من من
الامور المقلوفه في الحروب انك يمكن ان
تبداها لكن من الصعب ان تسيطر عليها
لمجموعه من الاسباب واحده من هذه الاسباب
هي الاخطاء اللي تحدث في ميدان المعركه
كندي في اوجه ازمه 1962 او ازمه صواريخ
كوبا اللي العالم كان فيها اقرب من اي وقت
يعني منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه الى
اندلاع حرب عالميه اخرى بين الاتحاد
السوفيتي والولايات المتحده الكلمه مشهوره
جدا بعد ان لاحظ ان الحرب كان يمكن ان
تندلع ليس لان الامريكان يرغبون في الحرب
ولا لان الاتحاد السوفيتي يرغب في الحرب
ولكن بسبب اخطاء ميدانيه غير مقصوده من
جنود وطبات في ميدان المعركه والكلمه
مشهوره
دائما في واحد سنفا بيتش ما بتوصلهوش
الرساله ما بيفهمش الاوامر وبيرتكب خطا قد
يؤدي الى اشعال حرب لم يكن احد ابدا يخطط
اليها ما دام السولار بجوار النار قد
تشتعل دائما الحرائق اشكركم ولنا مع
التطورات الحرب الروسيه الاخرانيه حلقات
اخرى همم قادمه ان شاء الله